pop
[Musique]
c'est prévisible il ya plusieurs suites
du cru on est hors ue a plaidé
sécuritaire les biennois de choix là il
a rien vu venir
moi je ne sors plus jamais on s'y
attendait pas du tout peut-être dans ce
cas là on est remboursé voilà à bord de
nos filiales avait pris son parapluie
fatale c'était fatal mais pourquoi
diable n'avait-il pas sur parade puis
enfin
[Musique]
hop
ces blessures marseille pour un pitch
ans furieux cash à ce soit soulagé dans
la gouttière deux sans toi
un homme va demander des comptes à son
voisin les maîtres du champ mal lui en
prend elle reçoit une raclée des coûts
qui va 5000 francs à leurs auteurs 5000
francs seulement car le tribunal a
reconnu l'existence de la provocation
annulé ce mot prononcé par l'adjoint au
maire de niort c'est l'effet d'une bombe
pour les futurs époux et leurs invités
annulé leur mariage obscur présents dans
le public ne veut pas qu'il devienne
mari et femme
ils veulent dire oui le maire dit non
allez on voit un pipi de chat de
collection 5000 français fait chiama
goutte que des liens dans l'existence
que des liens se lâchent les mets de
côté au plus tard bon voyons cette
histoire de mariage retardée parce que
une mauvaise blague enfin une
plaisanterie attendait les fiancés à la
mairie quelqu'un avait fait inscrire
intitulé sur leur dossier en gros ce qui
a complètement bouleversé la cérémonie
si bien préparée et voilà comment
peut-on raté le plus beau jour de sa vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et
j'étais étudiante et je les études
auxiliaire puériculture
mais il travaillait travail de chaud
comme boucher
ces rencontres et deux ans à une séance
de leur club c'est mon frère didier qui
est entraîneur de ce club donc je suis
allé là bas pour le var entraîné et j'ai
connu pascal à cette soirée et puis
après on s'est retrouvés chez mon frère
pour une soirée et de là on a continué à
se rencontrer
face à ce que pascal canfin santini et
puis moi aussi alors bon ça a été bon
trois ans que j'ai commencé à faire ce
sport du patin à roulettes et c'est un
soir en allant à l'entraînement que j'ai
rencontré la soeur de l'entraîneur les
bras bien
en avant derrière en avant derrière
vous faites bien de moi
julien lesquelles tout disons cela il
faut tout court
[Musique]
nous avons décidé de nous marier il ya
donc huit mois et on a commencé à faire
les mêmes impératifs aller
il cherchait demander d'abord ce qui
ferait comme document que comme papier
après on a été bref voir un corps sain
dans le traiteur puisqu'il falloir
quinze jours au moins avant le mariage
on a retourné à la mairie de donner ses
papiers et après on était à vouloir le
traiteur quelques jours avant pour dire
mais non content qu'on serait des
personnes huit jours avant le mariage on
a été voir le break pour remettre tout
ce qui restait à faire un mariage normal
cérémonie à la mairie suivie d'une
cérémonie religieuse et puis un repas
avec toute la famille les amis
tout ce qu'il y a dans un magasin choix
[Musique]
à
des époux se doivent mutuellement
fidélité secours et assistance
des plus assurent ensemble la direction
morale et matérielle de la famille
pourvoit à l'éducation des enfants et
préparent leur époux s'obligent
mutuellement à une communauté de vie au
nom de la loi
je vous déclare unis par les liens du
mariage sur et gère de vérification à
2000 soit voir les liens du mariage
tu réserves de vérification amis fans
[Musique]
on en sourit maintenant un peu qui me
tient énormément ça fait rire sourire
moi je croyais qu'on était plutôt parti
pour un art et remonte pour un mariage
[Musique]
voilà n'a rien derrière le rythme il
faut que je sois à la mairie dior tôt
revoir une chose pareille
il mariait pleurer que les marches de la
mairie c'est quand même ça après cinq
ans à s'atrophier vrai c'est vraiment
aberrant
parce que nous on est des petits je
pense que là quand on doit mériter un
livret de famille je pense qu'on est
aussi large que un des fils vraiment
fait pour toi si tu veux avec seal
puisque ces mêmes mots d'esprit n'aurait
pas la peine des tâches lui pour être
poli sachets de riz ce que tu te laisses
passer ici c'est très très vrai dégagé
je vous dis dégagé oulamae rigole plus
là alors on va rester qui en a eu le
temps de se présenter
gmail est en même temps le temps de
présenter les grands mères j'ai tonton
étant parfaitement ya passé sa colère
recoupé la famille parce que c'est vrai
que c'est difficile d'accepter un tel
était le programme il ya eu quand même
préjudice moral pour devant pour une
cérémonie aussi que tout le monde attend
quoi tendues avec impatiente et des
excuses aussi de la mairie la part de la
mairie c'est tout ce que j'attends
administrativement les choses
s'expliquent quelqu'un ait fait
connaître en disant qu'il était là marié
et qu'il annulait le dossier ça je ne le
savais pas au moment de la cérémonie
mais le lundi les choses étaient très
claires comme c'était les intéressés qui
était supposée avoir fait la démarche
est que les intéressés étaient là libres
et consentants qu'il n'y avait pas d'
empêchement majeur au mariage les choses
sont rentrées dans l'ordre si vous
voulez effectivement la cérémonie était
quelque peu troublé ce qui est
infiniment dommage mais le mariage
religieux ayant pu et j'ai fait en sorte
qu'il puisse se faire et bien moi je
souhaite si vous voulez que ça leur
porte chance
j'étais dans le fond de l'église et
j'attendais fabien nebraska
quand soudain arrive un émissaire de
et qui me dit voilà des les mariés
auront du retard parce qu'il ya eu un
petit problème à la mairie
ils ont trouvé un dossier sur lequel il
y avait une marque est annulé et quand
ils sont arrivés j'ai vu effectivement
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui s'était
passé mais je ne savais rien du tout
j'aurais dis comme je le fais d'habitude
j'ai ouvert les manies voilà soyez les
bienvenus dans cette église je ferais
bien et pascal avec tous vos amis
maintenant on va rentrer c'est pour
célébrer un événement qui est très
important alors par conséquent tout ce
que vous pouvez avoir
mais donc comme souci vous laisser tous
ici à l'entrée
on a pris quelques instants de
répétition pour voir les champs avec eux
pour qu'on puisse faire quelque chose
qui se tiennent mais de fait ça marche
et du premier coûte tout de suite
le mariage civil a été ratée il ya plus
rien du mariage civil
si on n'était pas passé à l'église après
on a un très mauvais souvenir du mariage
un jeu qu'on ne pense pas toujours ça
sans butin ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
un proverbe chinois nous dit ne va pas à
la chasse centre marc millet son mariage
sans ta chance et tout de même quelqu'un
qui s'est fait connaître en disant qu'il
était la mariée c'est un peu gros moi je
préfère penser qu'il s'agit d'une jeune
femme qui était jalouse et une envieuse
qui a voulu empêcher le bonheur des uns
parce que le bonheur des uns ça peut
donner des idées aux autres en sont qu
as tu un jour ces gens de divorcer
je me demande ce qui les attend maladie
dans un hôpital de toulouse de la
fenêtre de sa chambre et ne voient
qu'une chose un panneau publicitaire des
pep funèbres ce européenne que voilà une
campagne bien ciblés allez on ne pas
pouvoir déclarer sa flamme à l'élu de
son coeur ça la fiche mal
pour résoudre le problème en amoureux
bordelais loue un panneau publicitaire
de quatre mètres sur trois en face du
domicile de sa dulcinée le message
simple à paris je t'aime ça la fiche
bien aller 1 à sorgues vaucluse
les riverains de l'église étaient
perturbés par les bruyants et pas
nocturne qui provenait du clocher le
couple surpris par les pompiers de
chouettes amoureuse n'avait pas résisté
aux chaleurs du printemps qu'il fallait
bien arrêter les frais parlez en à
colmar et lecteur attentif des page
nécrologique du journal faisait
tranquillement déficit à domicile des
disparus alors précise des obsèques
annoncé cela finit par lui rapporter
deux années prison pour cambriolage rien
[Musique]
un talence près de bordeaux dans un
quartier dont la vie s'échappe peu à peu
les maisons basses succèdent aux
bâtiments industriels en ruines les gens
vivent ici font leurs courses vont à la
pharmacie ils se croisent dans la rue se
reconnaissent entre eux
on se souvient vaguement d'un homme qui
ne se séparait jamais de son béret ni de
son vélo solex
un jour il ya longtemps il a disparu
mais le paysage n'a pas changé il n'a
même pas été bouleversée qu'est-il
devenu le monsieur du 19 mai le 7 août
dernier
je cherchais mon charge sur les chercher
le voisin et on est passé par le mur ici
là où il ya les bars et
et on est rentrés par une petite fenêtre
qui donnait un côté le sort de
poulaillers qui a de votre côté et on y
rentre dans la maison et on étale jusqu
au buffet et on n'y est pas allé plus
loin bon quand on a vu les tas d'amis de
l'intérieur on y re sortie ça s'est
arrêté là et le lendemain matin bon je
voulais insister je suis repassé et
c'est là où j'ai trouvé quelque chose de
bizarre au niveau là où on était la
première fois j'ai allumé une bougie
j'ai voulu éclairer j'ai vu que j'étais
sûr sûr sûr un cadavre et je suis
ressorti je suis allé chercher le boisé
qui venu je suis arrivé et pour le faire
montre au voisin parce que bon donc à
darou ça n'arrive pas tous les jours
aussitôt après je suis allé à la
pharmacie pour appeler le rappeler les
inspecteurs
quand les pompiers arrivent sur place la
maison est fermé le jardin et dans un
désordre indescriptible
du jamais vu pour pouvoir le franchir
ils devront déployer la grande échelle
et marcher dessus
à l'intérieur pas de doute c'est bien un
squelette qui est couché dans la cuisine
le crâne appuyé sur un meuble les pieds
touchant la table ronde installés dans
la pièce au premier truc qu'on a vu
apparemment il était à table il est et
il est en train de manger et
il est tombé il ya une crise par hama on
est resté et avec l'inspecteur bornes
elle s'est trouvée une lettre comme ça
avec avec sono pour savoir qui c'était
on a trouvé du sud-ouest perdu là où il
a approché son boulot
et sur les sud-ouest donc l'avait classé
sud-ouest de caillavet le cheveu est 84
il y avait 2 86 bon apparemment ça
faisait un moment qu'il était
nouvelle épreuve pour les pompiers le
parquet du couloir de la maison est
pourri il s'effondre sous leurs pas
dans la maison la police pénètre dans
l'intimité du monsieur du 19 janvier au
poste de tsf un réchaud à alcool un lit
défoncé elle découvre ses goûts ses
habitudes ses manies ses obsessions les
cartons par tour des plus de vieux
journaux et une pièce remplie de
bouteilles près d'un millier contenant
de l'uriné les policiers trouvent aussi
des calendriers écrit à l'homme il
constate que les jours reportés sont
rayés au fil du temps le dernier
calendrier confectionnés et celui du
mois de juillet 1986 le 6 est rayé la
ligne du 7 est intacte le décès du
monsieur du 19 remonterait donc à cinq
ans il avait alors 66 un autre élément
accrédite l'hypothèse un ultime retrait
à la caisse des paris en date du 19 juin
et puis le dff et le service des eaux
n'ont ils pas couper les compteurs en
1987 pour facture impayée de son absence
personne ne s'est inquiété personne ne
s'est demandé ce qu'il faisait
je pense que dans le quartier en fait il
ya très peu de charme qui l'ont connu de
son vivant en fait parmi les gens que je
connais bon c'est vrai qu'il ya deux
mois que je suis là donc je connais pas
tous les voisins mais le voisin immédiat
le voyais des fois passé
deux fois par jour donc évidemment un
solex il passé et c'était bonjour
bonsoir c'était amical mais c'était pas
c'était pas plus que ce à quoi il venait
chez moi de tendance à acheter ou du
bifteck ou du pain ou du vin ou
quelquefois de la bière un litre de
bière un litre de vin mais c'était un
homme très correct poli mais qui ne
parlait pas c'était un homme d'une
corpulence moyenne un peu de couple
heureuse sur les joues coiffer toujours
d'un béret et il portait aussi un anorak
ne me rappelais marine je parle autant
que je me souvienne voilà
c'était un original il vivait tout seul
ce qui me frappe c'est que personne ne
s'en soit aperçu comme il voulait une
viennent parce qu'on venait à mourir
comme ça tous ceux qui les bordent pour
ça qu'il y avait un original
ils vivaient tous seuls des morts tous
bay ne vienne triste car le laisse
traîner comme ça tout seul va maintenant
quatre ans soit la clé rsa de cinq ans
et une vie qui a continué comme si de
rien n'était
le monsieur du 19 avait beau ne
fréquentez ne recevoir personne
il était connu dans un quartier où il
avait grandi et où chacun sait qu'il est
qui
ici pas de béton pas de tours
surpeuplées ici derrière chaque porte
il existe une mémoire et vaut mieux
péter en bonne compagnie de crever tout
seul proverbe limousin et ça c'est un
salon pas ordinaire du tout et qui est
d'ailleurs le seul en limousin et c'est
même un salon de coiffure pour tout dire
c'est à limoges une coiffeuse qui était
mal considéré par sa patronne s'est fait
mettre au piquet et oui au coin comme à
l'école où piqué
[Musique]
oh là là on entend que gisèle
cette affaire pour cent et là si pour
nous c'est fini vous avez gagné j'espère
bien sûr que je gagnais en vérité que de
gagner je vois je crois que je suis
assez grande je suis contente pour vous
gisèle s'il vous plaît regagnant d'un
petit problème dans les fermes que sir
couper les cheveux
oui et vous voulez fait une belle
couleur bien d'accord bien sûr vous
allez y arriver il ya pas de problème il
n'y a pas de problème durant ce combat
reste et même dans les fameux hauteur de
ton je suis gisèle j'ai 44 ans j'exerce
dans la coiffure depuis 20 ans ont 84 je
rentre dans une succursale d'un grand
salon parisien jusqu'en 88 tous les
ennuis ont commencé
la retenue peine véniel par rapport au
cachot où l exclusion temporaire la
retenue prive les lycéens de récréation
la suite d'une altercation avec le
manager on n'a pas voulu me répondre sur
des problèmes d'ordre financier
j'ai été obligé de faire du courrier sur
poitiers de téléphoner là ça n'a pas plu
du tout
c'est un petit peu mise à l'écart et
puis comme j'ai manifesté cette demande
j'étais plus loin j'étais devant le
conseil des prud'hommes qui eux m'ont
donné des conseils est ce qu'il fallait
faire alors à ce moment là on a commencé
par me supprimer quelques clientes comme
je peux pas rester sans rien faire je
prenais le ballet j'allais repasser les
peignoirs puis comme je ne cédait pas on
m'a empêché de passer le balai ont
empêché de repasser les peignoirs on m'a
empêché de faire les shampoings je
faisais plus rien des journées entières
des semaines entières de la plume de
pourcentage et n'avait comme fixe et
tous suivent et mon emploi au règlement
intérieur juste il fut la mise en oeuvre
d'une procédure disciplinaire ou de
poursuites approprié j'écris un monsieur
paris mais c'est regrettable parce qu'il
n'a pas voulu s'initier est ce qui se
passait dans son entreprise
et là ça a été la grosse punition
c'était la quarantaine complète et
ensuite c'était le piqué au mali pour le
mur les jambes écartées et les bas de
l'article sur le journal
c'est exactement ça il ya on n'a rien
inventé
heureusement du hast et un huissier pour
constater parce que sinon on aurait pu
dire à la vente
je suis resté deux jours entiers et
trois quarts d'heure battement quand
même pour aller me restaurer mais c'est
très long on a l'impression que ça ne va
pas s'arrêter les gens me font mal ça
brûle c'est l'histoire invraisemblable
paul audi
je pense que ces gens là et peut-être de
la famille de genre des ducs leiria
n'ont peut-être pas quand même enfin
c'est archaïque pop à méthode c'est pas
moi qui fait intervenir l'huissier c'est
mon avocate qui en a pris la décision
parce que pendant ma coupure justement
je l'avertît que le deuxième jour ça a
recommencé
je ne sais pas ce que le lendemain la
punition de quel ordre alors été et
c'est elle qui a pris l'initiative
le huissier venu au salon ayant nous
sommes hantés avec la direction au
premier étage
quelle a été sa réaction de cette chaire
gérant cette chaire est bien là répondu
devant l'huissier que de toute façon
c'était une punition lamballe
c'était pour que
mon bien ah ben oui pour elle c'était
vraiment normal c'était peu votre bien
mais vous avez quel âge j'ai 44 ans mais
même à l'école
non mais j'ai suivi ça vaut mieux en
rire qu'en pleurer et à jouer du
campement
maintenant oui je pense pas que j'aurais
agi comme ça mais on peut pas non plus
toujours réagir violemment face à la
violence parce que ça se serait retourné
contre elle et puis
mais c'est sûr que ça se passait quelque
chose qu'ils n'avaient pas attendu le
fouet quand j'espère que vous n'auriez
quand même pas charrier pas laisser
faire avec un fouet là vous avez accepté
je ne sais pas comment bien fait là
vraiment c'est pas gta énormément la
dignité
peut-être un des indemnités aussi pas de
raison pourquoi céder je n'avais rien
fait de mal j'ai une très bonne employée
enfants telles choses salon
et vous aviez vous y avait des clientes
autour de moi et personne n'a bougé
non mais c'est impossible on dit bien
c'est le rêve toujours de toute façon
vous garantis que c'était dommage que
j'aurais pas été la barque
bah oui c'est toujours ce côté parce que
j'aurai la jeu mais j'étais c'était
vraiment ça vraiment sale et personne ne
bouge bien fait comment vous regardez
comment vous n'avez qu'à cliquer moi
parce que moi je devais la mare on
conçoit se disputer quand on connait
split clairement et qu'on essaie de
faire comprendre les skis ski va pas ou
les choses aux personnes c'est bien mais
taper sur les doigts ou métro piqué ou
mettre en quarantaine la moi j'ai eu la
chance d'en plaute employés déjà
intelligent et je me suis pas
spécialement intelligent mais jeune
homme de dialogue et j'ai toujours
trouvé un terrain d'entente sans avoir
recours au piquet moi je piquais je m'en
sers pour toucher mes tomates
[Musique]
c'est une affaire qui a quand même fait
beaucoup de bruit mais à l'image ici
quelques temps bon il s'en rappelleront
toujours mais hugo ça sera un petit peu
oublié tout a changé parce que ça a été
la bascule d'autant plus que je sais que
la direction ne se gênent pas à mon
égard à 44 ans on peut toujours trouver
du travail quand on a envie de
travailler puisque j'ai retrouvé un
emploi je me sens bien je vais
redémarrer mais tout bascule enfin
écoutez vous avez gagné
je sais que je suis contente pour vous
c'est financière quand même ça doit être
dur c'est un mauvais cauchemar mais ça a
dû être dur quand même de pas fini la
punition c'est un mot qui doit être
maintenant rayé du dictionnaire on n'a
plus à punir les gens c'est c'est
terminé notre mission on s'explique on
dialogue est en avance montrent unis
plus c'est terminé
entre fois calculé les auteurs 10 pour l
ongle euros mois
c'est une opération simple suffit d'un
agent de soleil et de planter et côté
pair dont la dimension elle est connue
et ses petits faits ces menus à lien
c'est que nombre la tour ils permettent
de révéler nous peur nos envies les les
fantasmes de l'humanité qui sont là
dessous la tour c'est notre corps social
la tour c'est l'humanité en érection
je vais écrire une nouvelle
je vais écrire une petite nouvelle sur
quelqu'un qui aimait tellement sa
maîtresse d'école et qu'elle me theiss
ses camarades au piquet par le président
de la république
document lui rendant hommage pour sa
[ __ ] rendus à la france durant la
première guerre mondiale
né le 2 octobre 1918 ce héros n'était
donc âgé que de quelques semaines le
jour de l'armistice
mais quelle fête armes qu'elle biberon
que lui valoir une telle récompense
battu à saint tropez ou pas
le code de procédure pénale précise
qu'un suspect doit être fouillée par un
agent du même sexe à bordeaux ayant
arrêté a travesti les policiers
perplexes se demander qui devait
procéder à la fouille marc hé bien c'est
facile pour les écologistes et les
vagabonds fatigué écrit son histoire
le récit est publié et le livre va
devenir a filmé les chemins de la gloire
sont décidément impénétrables a l'air
vraiment voilà une ombre mesurables le
vagabondage le vagabondage qui transpire
en chacun de nous qui dégouline parce
que le vagabond c'est l'homme de
l'imprévisible du hasard c'est celui qui
fait peur parce qu'ils nous ressemblent
par en dessous
nos sociétés se sont d'abord des
rassemblements de nomades des nomades
arrêté enfin pour écrire il faut bien
s'arrêter un peu peut pas écrire en
marchant
[Musique]
les routes parce qu'il y avait déjà
vingt 20 ans que la route était dans ma
tête j'étais sédentarisés par
l'infection
c'est parce que j'étais avec une avec
une femme avec givet que j'aimais
beaucoup ce n'est pas le couler sur la
route
vous avez mené auprès d'elle enfin je
vais voir si je suis resté pendant 13
ans mais j'étais un nomade dans ma tête
j'étais jamais été fixe dès mon enfance
ça a été en finale ça a été mes grands
parents étaient à droite et à gauche lui
et varié donc c'était c'était de la
sédentarisation de compensation et c'est
parce que j'avais là un gros blocs
affectif elle comporte en plus quand
elle est morte
[Musique]
les vagabonds le jour où il est rentré à
l'orphelinat
il a compris qu'il serait peut-être la
gamme en toute sa vie toi et c'est vrai
omar fois on en a la bombe était bon ce
qu'on peut appeler un gratte-papier on
gratte papier type 1 socialiser formés
et socialiser voilà les vagabonds en
général bon c'est vrai que c'était des
gens qui n'avaient jamais abordé
auparavant et je j'étais quand même très
surprise par son vocabulaire par ces
cultures et
ça m'a permis bon c'est vrai que lui
même dit qu'il veut partir aristocratie
de la route
alors on est sur la route comme devant
un film les gens passent les le temps
les justes bull et les choses sont
vraiment en on pense en noir et blanc et
en vie en couleurs c'est assez curieux
et on vit avec un espèce de mur
bien en face de soi lorsqu'on et
vagabond a en face de soi des gens
on est nu monstre de soin de les gens
nus le vagabonde n'est qu'un miroir de
l'homme quitte en face l'homme exact est
en place
[Musique]
bon il ya un peu de sexualité mais les
rares où enseigne danger lui je crois je
vais concourir à 17 ou 18 villes à faire
quoi dans cette dent or ceux ci manquent
du fait de femmes
c'est énorme dit cette femme en
septembre ça fait dix-sept où on va la
nuit
c'est donc très peu quoi puis maintenant
appareils quand même chez les nouveaux
regardons les poupées gonflables dans
les sacs à dos
foyer d'accueil il y avait un tribun
groupe d'arrêter d'acheter une poupée
gonflable quatre ans et trois mois elle
avait récupéré sa poupée gonflable parce
que le soin vous ai payé 10 balles la
passe à ses potes oui donc c'est assez
marrant pour poupée gonflable prostituer
pour effet la première de france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya deux bons jours pour faire une
manche
c'est le jour de noël une fois par an et
aux élections présidentielles fois tous
les sept ans oui il suffit de prendre un
panneau sur lequel on a marqué on a
gagné
quel que soit le vainqueur les gens qui
seront dans la rue à huit heures du soir
pense que c'est un sympathisant et
naturellement ça dégringole
et puis ça si la merde
ce qu'on veut c'est pas tous les jours
parce que parmi les vagabonds de la
femme à 10% de facho parce que
danse pas les jours parce qu'on dise à
trois publics d'habitude parce que parce
que socialement
l'écurie
marcher sur la route il était grand il
n'avait pas de point de chute ni deux ni
de maison à lui et il est revenu nous
voir comme ça un jour d'hiver il
n'allait pas très bien et c'est là que
beaucoup de choses ont commencé
c'était un soir d'hiver et on voit un
grand gars rentrer dans la maison et
nous dire voilà il faut que je vienne
pour parler j'ai des choses à dire je
peux plus bouger par ne plus arriver à
vivre si je parle pas il nous a raconté
sa propre histoire
et puis là raconte t il à raconter des
jours et des jours et puis nous on en
avait un petit peu assez de cette
histoire là qu'on entendait toujours et
comme il est on savait qu'il écrivait
sur la route des histoires qu'il notait
sur un petit carnet on lui a dit que
toute cette histoire là haut lieu nous
la raconter maintenant on la connaît par
coeur tu devrais la l'écrire soit sur
ton carnet et puis pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas offert un livre fut riche et des
amis dans le limousin
et puis ses amis m'ont hébergé pendant
trois mois ils m'ont donné une de la
vierre porte plume du papier une chambre
à leur bibliothèque et qui monte il
faudrait qu'elle était tout ça si l'on
fait pour qui le soulage
j'ai écrit puis voilà j'ai le rsa et
suivant trois mois quatre mois ils ont
fui un plus et un beau jour n'a réussi
que le contrat photocopier des éditions
denoël donc nous nous provoque son
bouquin mais avait été acceptée été
publiés par de noël
les vagabonds dans la majorité des cas
c'était entre 18 et 20 attente ils
rejoignent le cirque est moins jolie
passe et plus auront besoin d'un passé
sur la route point de passer allègrement
on est
damien
et celle-là des moutons influencé par
rabelais un groupe de 60 brebis s'est
précipitée du haut d'une falaise de 50 m
dimanche après-midi une brebis frappé
d'affolement a d'abord sauté dans le
vide
immédiatement suivie par l'ensemble du
troupeau trois d'entre elles ont
succombé à leurs blessures
trente autres ont dû être abattus
et c'est toujours l'histoire des moutons
de panurge la même héros risée par le
passage à basse altitude d'une
montgolfière dix cochons sont mortes
d'une crise cardiaque
et dans le ciel tu es un ballon
d'oxygène
c'est ce qu'on appelle met alors au pied
de la lettre
être mort de peur et sa boîte des
cochons il n'empêche qu'il s'agit de
l'épouvanté fondamentale celle et
pouvant de ce qui nous passe au dessus
de la tête toujours la peur vient d'en
haut elle est constant c'est la peur
qu'au smic c'est la peur panique on sait
strahl d origine la mort vient du ciel
toujours toujours la mort des cendres
c'est la foudre c'est lé clair c'est les
comètes dieu même est épouvantable les
premiers hommes se sont toujours
couverts la tête par crainte c'est ce
qu'on appelle la terreur sacrée
le danger vient d'en haut
[Musique]
c'est la flore qui existaient à l'époque
de l'homme de 0,12 ya soixante dix mille
ans et on refait le même sentier que les
gens de leur histoire avaient emprunté
toujours partout il y aller car elle
n'aimait clientèle pour être pas à
l'érosion
autrefois il y avait des peaux de mouton
les boîtes et devient obtenu maintenant
c'est terminé ça devient d'un jeune et
de dangers pour les incendies le
gisement
basco et sur la colline en face juste là
et il y avait de l'eau en abondance et
c'est un passage obligé des animaux pour
les animaux là parce que est passé ici
on bat la lozère et ils ont emprunté
arrivé à travers des collines si ce sont
des lieux ça tous sont d'une importance
considérable ce sont des religieux
lettre de monsieur roger constant au
colonel commandant la base aérienne de
bordeaux le 19 mars 1990 mon colonel
je suis propriétaire et conservateurs
d'un site classé monument historique de
renommée mondiale
le riz gourdou distant de quelques
centaines de mètres des grottes de
lascaux
par la présente je vous lance un cri
d'alarmé car depuis plusieurs jours déjà
des avions de chasse survolent la région
les banques sonic ont ébranlé le sol
provoquant des bruits très inquiétant
sous le plancher de ma maison elle même
classé monument historique
les chiens or ici en bas c'est la grande
sépulcrale à l'origine c'est une voûte
qui recouvrait tout et qui s'avançait
jusque devant la maison elle sondage a
été fait et ce sondage nous a dit que
c'était creux l'excavation a donc
commencé en mars 1954 et en septembre
1957 énorme fut découvert en sépulture
et ce fut l'homme de type néandertaliens
qui se trouvait près de la roche son âge
- quatre-vingt mille ans un des plus
vieux spécimens de la race
c'est une des communes les plus
impatients douce ou le pays
comment thinel le seul à vous de se
tourner vers 1960 davut étaient fondées
j'avais des scientifiques allaient
devoir lever nomme alors alors plus ses
fruits personne ne s'est étonné ce fait
la découverte en 1961 ce sont des chants
3,64 à découvert des sculptures les
housses
les allemands avaient déjà mais les
cooper en afrique mans il avait d'abord
fait des constructions de petits
monuments pia sert très bien soignée et
dans lesquelles est monstrueux mais
d'abord déposer de cannes au milieu et
certains les animaux sont le jamais
déposé milieu et des ossements sur des
positionnements autour du tram c'est la
présence aime les gens que j'ai vus sur
l actuel
[Applaudissements]
ces survols sont à l'origine d'un second
problème d'importance en effet afin de
valoriser ce haut lieu de la préhistoire
j'ai aménagé un parc dans lequel vivent
trois ours symbole vivant de ce que fut
le culte de l'ours célébré par nos
lointains ancêtres en cet endroit
or les banques et frais les ours et
leurs réactions de panique me font
craindre pour leur santé
les allemands japon beaucoup de choses
et ce alors elle lui donne la recette
authentique ont fait les voilà ça
faisait de très intelligent qui nous
comprennent qu il nous observe et que
nous comptons simplement par contre les
animaux nous sommes la venue de
momification et mes chiens à main lui
smoby fille sur place il ya des forces
considérables c'est un des centres du
monde ici mais comme il s'en vend plus
interpréter mais les animaux savent
la présidence de la république à
monsieur roger constant le 4 avril 1981
je suis chargé de vous faire connaître
que votre requête a été transmise à
monsieur le ministre de la défense
du général de division aérienne
commandant la troisième région aérienne
à monsieur roger constant
le 21 mai 1990 afin d'éviter tout risque
de dégradation de panique de la faune du
régourdou j'ai l'honneur de porter à
votre connaissance de l'armée de l'air a
décidé d'en interdire le survol à très
basse altitude
les avions d'abord parce que cette
colline depuis 1970 et possédant jusqu'à
six fois par jour et là il ya eu 2 au
sol au mois de janvier dernier et on a
bien su personae passé juin chasseurs il
a passé un seuil par sept à huit est
faisable y standing avec un coup bas
mais alors la mère de la culture tu t'es
des amours et ses deux petits
tiens on peut maintenant non mais là
c'est ch est mort ce qui est lamentable
c'est une honte pour la société actuelle
et les lundis ci vise à ce qu'ils ont
possédé
on ne trompe pas la baisse de la demande
à l'homme au 200 m 2 de la bête parce
que la bêta beaucoup plus l'inspecteur
beaucoup plus de dignité les éléments
beaucoup plus de dignité comme une mère
ourse qui tue ses petits d'un seul coup
et qui les mange parce que le monde
mécanique vient de passer comme ça
brusquement il a fait disjoncter
impressionnant mais je pense au jour où
les mamans vont devenir aux graisses et
où elles vont tuer leurs petits enfants
leur bébé parce que nous vivons dans des
nuisances insupportable et à moins que
ce soit déjà commencé ça l'habitante de
vienne dans l'isère appelle son médecin
elle s'inquiète des rôles qu'elle entend
à l'autre bout du fil elle très bien les
pompiers trop fort le docteur les mots
victime d'un infarctus attentes
et de besançon un chasseur a reçu une
volée de plombs dans le bas-ventre banal
accident de chasse non c'est son chien
qui a tiré un chien sachant chasser doit
savoir chasser 100 m allez d'abord dont
a beaucoup hésité avant d'appeler les
pompiers de quimper pour qu'il vienne le
départ à sept années de guerre
il est vrai que les seins de madame
bidons se trouvait fort bien chez celles
faites ça crée des petits noeuds cité
des abeilles voilà un proverbe chinois
mieux vous une poignée d'abeilles qu'un
sac de mouches et maintenant si vous
avez chez vous de beaux aléas et même
des aléas ordinaire envoyez les moi s'il
vous plaît j'en ferai mon miel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
p
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]